jeff we talked about a lot of signs in
las vegas
can you possibly narrow it down to
maybe your grandfather's favorite your
favorite and your father's favorite
so my grandfather's favorite sign had to
be the boulder club uh and it's here
pictured on the wall um the thing he put
right on the bullnose was the depiction
of the boulder dam which really was the
impetus to create the new economy here
and create a lot of power which he
viewed as a big opportunity for him to
build more signs
in the case of my father it has to be
the mint he had a 60 millimeter uh
camera
a film camera and filmed its
construction and so we have some
unbelievable footage of that sign going
up and i think that's why he's drawn to
that for me it has to be the hard rock
guitar the first of all the world's
guitars the guy came warwick stone came
to town with a with a 70 000 budget and
we sold him a 280 000 guitar we leased
it so we kept title to it and so when it
came to end of life
we were in a position to donate to the
neon museum so there it sets for
generations to come and so that's why
that sign is most meaningful to me